Antonio Browns not in the building today
won't be practicing I don't have any
more information for you right now and
when I have some and it becomes
appropriate you guys all get it I
promise you but that's it for today I'm
emotional about it I hope you hope you
understand why I think a lot of this guy
I mean the Antonio is a great receiver
and I think deep down he's a really good
guy
so I'm frustrated I'm not gonna say any
more about it hope it all works out but
I don't have anything official to say
about anything else until I get all the
facts oh my gosh Antonio Brown every
time we think it's under control it
blows up again and this incident that
both mike Mayock and john burton we're
addressing on Thursday it has its roots
in Wednesday's decision by Brown to put
on Instagram a fine letter he had
received from general manager mike
Mayock right indicating that he was
being fine fifty-three thousand nine
hundred fifty dollars Antonio Brown
wasn't happy about that there was an
incident practice on Wednesday where
Antonio Brown had to be physically
restrained from Mayock it started with
chirping Mayock said my understanding is
to brown look we just prefer that you
handle this stuff internally sure it
escalated vantes Burfict of all people
reportedly was one to hold back Antonio
Brown and brown sent home wasn't there
yesterday this all came out on Thursday
with news from ESPN that the Raiders are
planning to suspend Antonio Brown which
means he's not suspended ya know which
means I think Chris and I believe this
now it's been almost 24 hours yeah
there's an effort one last chance is
this guy gonna comply is he gonna grovel
is he gonna do what he has to do to make
this right and understand going forward
he's gonna be down to his final
opportunity to be all in we think their
last opportunity this is strike 47 now
we're on ok yeah you still have a head
coach who's defending him right and he's
still Antonio Browns hearing that and
going with coach is still in my corner
are you saying there may be more than
one final opportunity I don't
I'll believe it when I see it just like
I got to see a lot of things in the NFL
but I mean again I think Jon Gruden is
overflowing love with the player here is
is also playing into this situation
where Antonio Brown goes there the red
carpets out for me the coach loves me
he's my guy I mean he just all he does
is talk to me and placate to me and now
I'm the man and Mayock trying to go holy
crap we got to get control of the
organization here in the locker room
what the hell is going on and I
understand where mike Mayock might be
like this is not I mean we know Mayock
enough you know I'm probably better than
I do but he is an old-school guy I mean
this is not the kind of locker room or
organization he wants to to deal with
and yeah I mean are we really shocked by
this no no man if Gordon wants to give a
Antonio Brown another chance or more
right at some point does burden have to
choose between Antonio Brown and mike
Mayock I I don't think he does I I mean
I hope he doesn't I I would think at
this point there's your mark at some
point aren't you saying damn it John I
didn't come yes he's gonna have that to
deal with this right and go back down I
found out right right I don't need this
yeah no I would be saying that I I get
it and I would think mike Mayock said
that I don't think he's scared to say
that to anybody I really don't so I I
would imagine that conversations gone
down I would like I think Gruden more
than anything is the guy that's going to
have to be Stern with Antonio Brown
Antonio Brown I think at this point
would realize Jon Gruden loves him he
wanted them there he's the reason he's
on the Oakland Raiders and got the 30
million dollars guaranteed but I also
think Jon Gruden has to be the guy just
like you know you do as a father
sometimes you got to be hey I love you
son but this is how you're supposed to
act and if I if I'm gonna raise you the
right way I gotta teach you things that
you might not like and that might like
me for it right now at this moment but
in the big picture of the team your life
everything this is gonna help us and you
personally and I think that conversation
has to go down it really does because
they're gonna lose control of the locker
room we talked about it before I mean
they told him not to go yesterday don't
be there because they're afraid he's
gonna get in the locker room they got a
lot of young you know impressionable
guys who were going wet this is what you
do in the NFL and they want to be
friends with Antonio Brown because he's
cool and he's on Instagram and he's
driving Lamborghini suvs and he's got a
lot of things all the players strive for
in the NFL and they're gonna kind of
look at him and go whoa this is this is
what happens in the NFL David Carr the
older brother of Derek Carr said on NFL
Network yesterday that according to
Derek the team captains went to Jon
Gruden and said whatever you decide is
fine he stays he goes whatever is fine
there you go so that tells you a little
right there right right so we still
don't know what's going on with the
situation and nothing has changed really
in the last 12 hours if Jon Gruden yeah
was fully aware of all the warts if
there was no effort by Mike Tomlin to
you know to downplay to conceal anything
yeah Rudin knew everything that Tomlin
had ever dealt with you think Jon Gruden
still would have said I can fix this guy
can change I do I don't think it would
have scared him and now this is part of
the greatness of John Gurdon - I mean
Jon Gruden is great with personalities
he's got great personality you know when
you are when when you are a good player
on a football team okay
Gruden can make you feel like you're
that special and hey I'm gonna make
special place for you and he can really
empower you that way and he was great
that way of communicating and doing
things like that when I was playing for
him in Tampa Bay but I do think he has
the ultimate confidence or self
confidence in myself
to go oh okay I've heard some of the
horror stories but I'm pretty good with
people and I know how to work with these
big x star baller type players Jeff
Keyshawn Johnson well yeah okay and but
that was a little different because I
don't you know Keyshawn wasn't the
Balmer that Antonio Brown is and that's
no disrespect to you Keshawn Keyshawn
was a really good football player but
come on Antonio Browns like first-ballot
hall-of-famer
right now as far as what he's done on
the football field and I do think Gruden
is the kind of guy that has the self
confidence the arrogance whatever you
want to say to go oh I heard all the
horror stories but I've seen the guy
practice I see the juicy brings to the
football field and I see what he's doing
on the field when I watch Phillip and
it's special and I can make it work with
this guy I think he is capable of doing
that
I raise an interesting question Antonio
Brown I have to look at his career staff
yes if he's just done and no one else
touches him right he can't establish a
foothold anywhere else in the NFL I
don't think he's got enough you don't
think he's got an eye
to look at I got a look I don't think
XFL stats are gonna count no well it
wouldn't it be something if that's where
he ends up although he has to undergo a
fundamental change cuz he has undergone
a fundamental shift throughout the
course of this year right where he just
no longer complies he no longer plays
along and he's got to get back to that
point or he's never gonna be on another
football team
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports